Vô YT lấy ý kiến lần đầu cho đe an thực hiện miến viện viện viện viện thống y quyết mấy mẹi
hướng tới bảo đảm quyền chăm sóc xức quẻ và giảm gánh năng chí vị trong người dân.
Châu mùa táng miệ hài, mô YT tổ chức hội thảo sin ý kiến chuyên gia
về định hướng xây dựng đe an tình bức miến viện viện viện viện dựa trên đàn mắc phù bảo hiểm y tế bọn dân.
Thứ trường thường trực vũ mạnh hà cho biết tỷ lệ mắc phù bảo hiểm y tế đàn hơn 7 mươi thương phần chăm.
Mạnh lưới khám chứ vệ mở giống, năng lực các tuyến được năng lên.
Tuy vậy, chí tiêu tiền tuy của người dân vẫn ở mất cao ước tính khoảng hơn 1 mi phần chăm
tổng chí vị y tế, tìm bàn nguy cơ nghe hoá so bánh tật nhất là với người nghe hoá và nhóm sẽ tổn thường.
Chù trường miến viện viện viện viện được sắc định lại yêu cầu cấp thiết, nhằm giảm gánh năng tài chính,
tăng công bằng trong tiếp cận y tế và khuyến kích người dân khám chứ bệnh sớm hơn.
Theo vụ bảo hiểm y tế, gọi dịch vụ y tế cơ bàn sẽ được sắc định gió sang mục bàn,
thuốc, thiết bị và ký thuật phù hợp khả năng lên sách, bảo đam người dân được hưởng miến viện cho phạm viện bảo hiểm.
Các chuyên giản dân định chính xác sẽ có phần thu hẹp chình lệ xí khỏe giữa các nhóm dân cư giám nguy cơ hộ ra đình dưới vào nhau đó với VGVE tế,
đồng thời cùng cũng có niềm tím của nhân dân vào chính xác y tế và an sinh xã hội.